Record a little bit for our behind the scenes?
Oh yeah of course! *pew*
-Alright pay attention, Sam's about to wow ya
SAM:Wow Ya
Waitin' on a plane, gonna take me down to margarita ville
so I can be super cheesy .
Get it? See what I did there?
So when you dry fire a bow, the limbs
vibrates that cause the foam to vibrate
off the edges; also when you pull back in
a recurve the string lifts off the ends
of the limbs here to cause it to rip off
the tape and make these all off
I hate acting but don't tell anyone else
that
Thankfully I planed on being wrapped by
six so we can actually be done by seven-
CARMICHAEL: What time is it?
-It's 4:15
We do have to get back to Hunter
Street though so we can shoot this with
enough light
but as long as we're back there by Oh... 5:30, we'll be ok
It's Matt from the Game Theorist here.
HEY! Today I'm a doctor.
Fun fact when I was in high school
actually got something sent to me in the
mail. On the like envelope dear Dr.
Matthew Patrick, please test out
Tylenol Extra Strength on your patients,
here's a sample
so you can start testing it out so there
you go I finally achieve that moment.
That's what it takes like once Tyleol
sends a message
Right? That's like, screw
paper works for the PhD man! Done.
Let's see some cool stuff.
SAM: So this week we did a shoot, a racing drone shoot,
These guys are like literally the
drone racing champions.
Oh my god, look at that shot!
Oh, mouth and throat yes. Still has it.
Have you seen this thermal camera?
Whoa! You are, you're pretty hot right now
I mean I don't need a thermal camera to
be able to tell that though!
Oh yeah jokes. Jokes! Humor!
So, that's awesome is that an app?
So it's a camera attachment that you get
Oh, no way!
Can you confirm that man in there
has an unknown deadly virus?
I can I just came from there.
Ah, and can you also confirm that there's absolutely no
way anyone can save him?
Sadly yes that man will die.
Also can you confirm your real doctor?
I can.
You got three, two, one BOOOAAAHH
*Whisper* Three, two, one...
WHOOO! What! What the fuck was that!
So, we got a hit of a quick lunch meeting
here are super super cool friend Ricky Raype
we're gonna go talk about other big
project ideas
As you guys might be familiar with we've
been working on all these documents and
pitches and treatments and stuff for all
these other big projects want to do
we may have found someone who is interested
in pursuing them with us.
And now I've got to do all the effects for
video that they plan to have so many
effects and they didn't realize how many
effects are going to be in there
And now I have four days to do two weeks worth
of work
Lets get to it.
I actually wrote out all
the different effects here and I printed
it and I put it on the wall
no matter what things I have open on my
screen, I immediately see what shots still
need to be worked on... Which is a lot.
How many of you guys have a Myspace?
Where Niko throws a shield, it hits some tree
leaves up here bounces off the tree then
bounces off the ground
some fleas live away?... Leaves fly away andthen they bounce into the room.
We have this dilemma
how do we do the shot? The obvious way is
to get a 3d model, texture it and then
you can animate it doing the whole thing
but we have three days and we haven't
even begun modeling it
Uh, hold on,let me get my... there you go. There you go!
Coffee!
You're dragging today!
My body my brain and my stomach all hurt.
JAKE: How's it going man?
C-MICHEAL: I was here till 3am
JAKE: Till 3am?
C-MICHEAL:Yeah.
JAKE: What were you doing?
C-MICHEAL: Making up for the time that I actually spent in VR
Sound design, let me know if you want a tutorial.
So it's like he animated the arrow
to split as the other arrow comes in and
as we're looking at the footage it's like,
huh, that's odd
the arrows like the air like anticipates
the arrow coming so it's like,
I welcome you to me
Going into the whole
here. Ready? And three two one,
EVERYONE: WHOOOAAA!
Yeah actually looks really good, look at
paint out.
It's so ready.
No more Apple box
-You coming in Friday?    - Yes
-Is that an all day thing are you coming at like 1?
-Like one.
Remember when start button wouldn't work
on Windows 10?
-Yeah
I'm having that problem again
-Don't upgrade to Windows 10 folks
No matter how much, you know
reset when you hit the reset button.
It's like "Bloop!" dead.
things are actually going pretty well to
being on Tuesday was like there's all
these effects and I can't do all of them
in three days
but it turns out when you have two of
the people helping you can do other
things you can do more things you could
if we can you can solve cancer
-You gonna work over the weekend?
-Hell no
I'm gonna sleep, I'm gonna eat some sushi
I'm gonna ride my long board up to the
mountain listen to my audiobook such
good plans
-Don't get attacked by a cougar.
-That's only happened once dude, come on
and she was at least 45
you're digging too fast you might
destroy the hentai!
Oh no if only I could get the hentai! See that there, it's a part!
Watch out for them zombie though!
He's digging for hentai cards
-You gotta find those cards dude.
-They're collectibles.
-Not just Hentai cards but collectibles? Jeez
-My collectible Hentai cards!
Oh what is this one?
Oh, what is this one? oooooo....
*Inaudible*
yo Carmicheal, you wanna drown out?